einfach ausgedrückt ist dies eine der
beeindruckendsten wissenschaftlichen
Leistung des 21 Jahrhundert so die
us-energieministerin Jennifer grenold an
der National ignition facility der Neff
ist etwas absolut bahnbrechendes
gelungen und Michael binderbauer von
theaet technologies setzt noch einen
drauf wir werden bis zum Ende des
Jahrzehntes das erste Fusionskraftwerk
haben deshalb hier ein Klick zum Special
noch mal mit einem exklusiv Interview
eines ganz besonderen Forschers los
geht's
herzlich willkommen das ist ein absolut
sensationeller Durchbruch bei der
Kernfusion zum ersten Mal in der
Geschichte der Erforschung der
Fusionstechnologie wurde in einem
Experiment mehr Strom erzeugt als
verbraucht damit ist man den Beweis dass
die Kernfusion tatsächlich zu
Energiegewinnung genutzt werden kann
einen Schritt näher gekommen Michael
binderbauer ist einer der führenden
kernfusionsforscher weltweit größte
Sprung auf jeden Fall nicht ich meine
psychologisch anfängt das zu beurteilen
das ist so eigentlich wie der erste der
die vier Minuten Meile übersprungen hat
nicht so unter vier Minuten die Meile
laufen konnte oder die ersten die
Hillary der den Mount Everest es ist
oder right Brothers mit dem Flug nicht
das sind zwar alles kleine kleine selbst
die haben die haben den dem die
Auswirkung dass man dann einfach nicht
mehr Zweifel ist es möglich ist es
reduziert doch praktisch ist hat das
gesehen das ist so ist eine demostation
der Möglichkeit und das dann weiter
umsetzen
emotionell ist ein großer Unterschied im
Gegensatz zur Kernspaltung hat die
Kernfusion viele Vorteile bei der
Spaltung entsteht eine Kettenreaktion
die auch gewollt wie bei der Atombombe
oder ungewollt bei kraftwerksunfällen
außer Kontrolle geraten kann und es
entstehen radioaktive Abfallprodukte die
teilweise Millionen Jahre strahlen und
lebensgefährlich sind keiner dieser
Nachteile besteht bei der Kernfusion
geringe Strahlung kaum Abfälle und es
entsteht keine unkontrollierbare
Kettenreaktion es könnte die Technologie
sein um tatsächlich ewig Energie zu
erzeugen ein Gramm Brennstoff liefert zu
viel Energie wie 11 Tonnen Kohle es wird
keinerlei CO2 freigesetzt saubere
Energie in schier unendlicher Menge das
ist die Vision die mit der Hilfe der
Kernfusion zu Realität werden soll laut
Neff könnten die ersten Kraftwerke mit
dieser Technologie in den nächsten
Jahrzehnten gebaut werden die
Energieerzeugung durch kann Fusion
könnte jedoch schon viel früher beginnen
das US-Unternehmen TAE technology sagt
dass es noch gegen Ende dieses
Jahrzehnts soweit sein wird der fünfte
Forschungsreaktor des US-Unternehmens
TAE technologies heißt Norman mit ihm
hat man es geschafft ein stabiles Plasma
bei über 70 Millionen Grad Celsius
erzeugen und die Visionen von thi sind
riesig diese Technik soll jetzt
weiterentwickelt werden so dass sie
bereits in wenigen Jahren zum
kommerziellen Einsatz kommen kann das
US-amerikanische Unternehmen thi wurde
1998 gegründet und hat 2015 erstmals
bewiesen dass ein in sich geschlossenes
Plasma 10 Millisekunden lang vollständig
stabil gehalten werden kann dann vor
drei Jahren 2019 ein weiterer Erfolg
damals gelang es ein Plasma
infusionsreaktor Normen über 30
Millisekunden lang bei rund 35 Millionen
Grad Celsius stabil zu halten in diesem
Jahr zeigte das Unternehmen dass Normen
das Plasma bei über 70 Millionen Grad
stabil halten kann weniger als ein
Faktor zwei von Temperatur entfernt die
für die Zündung von herkömmlichen
fusionsbrennstoff erforderlich ist im
Vergleich zum nifreaktor der zum ersten
Mal mehr Energie erzeugt hat als
indiffusion gesteckt wurde ist die
Technologie von thi näher an der
Kommerzialisierung Normen arbeitet nicht
in einem pulsierenden Betriebszyklus
sondern läuft konstant hier war es
möglich dass Plasma genauer zu
analysieren und zu optimieren und das
Prinzip ist von Tai deutlich effizienter
als dass der Neff der Laser ist relativ
ähm ineffizienten nicht also relativ
gesehen sehr effiziente ungefähr ein
zwischen einem Zehntel vielleicht ein
Prozent in höchststellen und was wir
verwenden ist wir verwenden Teilchen
Beschleuniger und wir Prototypen gebaut
von diesen Teilchen Beschleuniger die
bis zum 90% effizient sind das heißt
also das Umsetzen in ein Kraftwerk ist
ein wesentlicher Stück von der von der
Arbeit die noch nötig ist und das alles
zusammenzubringen also wir haben sobald
die wir physikalisch zeigen können dass
wir nettoenergie gewinnen können das
Umsetzen in ein Kraftwerk ist ein
wesentlich kürzerer Weg als wie das die
nicht hat so entschied sich das
Unternehmen für einen Ansatz der sich
von anderen fusionsprojekten
unterscheidet das heiße Plasma wird
durch ein weitgehend selbst erzeugtes
Magnetfeld und die Teilchenbeschleuniger
Strahltechnik stabil gehalten außerdem
soll bohrwasserstoff verwendet werden
die sauberste sicherste und am
häufigsten vorkommende Brennstoff Option
für die Fusion und das sind nur einige
der bahnbrechenden Innovationen die Tai
auszeichnen ein starkes externes
Magnetfeld wie es im Großprojekt Itter
hier in Europa verwendet wird ist nicht
erforderlich mit anderen Worten riesige
Energiemengen zur Aufrechterhaltung des
Magnetfelds sind somit überflüssig
darüber hinaus wurde Tee durch die
Physik von Teilchenbeschleuniger
inspiriert wie sie beispielsweise im
europäischen Forschungszentrum CERN
eingesetzt werden laut die kann die
Kombination aus selbst erzeugten
Magnetfeldern und der junge Injektion
von hoch energetischen Plasmateilchen
das Plasma sehr stabil und
kontrollierbar machen noch besser je
höher die Temperatur im TA ihre Aktor
desto stabiler wird das Plasma
paradoxerweise wird die
Aufrechterhaltung des Plasmas mit
steigender Temperatur also nicht
unbedingt schwieriger sondern wie die
Tai gezeigt hat sogar einfacher das ist
wie ein Kreisel der umso stabiler bleibt
je schneller er sich dreht das
Unternehmen sieht seine bisherigen
Erfolge daher als Bestätigung dafür dass
sich das heiße Plasma mit einem bis zu
einem gewissen Grad selbst erzeugten
Magnetfeld und einer ausreichenden
Injektion schneller Ionen selbst
stabilisiert und das ist wahrhaftig ein
meine Stein die letzten Fortschritte
führten dazu dass das Unternehmen eine
Finanzierungsrunde abschließen konnte
insgesamt schossen Investoren über 1,2
Milliarden US-Dollar hinzu Tai will
damit unter anderem einen weiteren
Reaktor bauen geplant ist der Bau einer
Demonstrationsanlage namens Kopernikus
hier werden dann Plasma Temperaturen von
mehr als 100 Personen Grad Celsius
möglich sein um mit dem tei-ansatz einen
ähnlichen nettoenergiemeilenstein wie
nicht zu erreichen ist dieser Schritt
erreicht steht einem kommerziellen
Kraftwerk nichts mehr im Weg dies
bezeichnet das Unternehmen als da Vinci
das wäre deutlich früher als es bei
allen anderen Verfahren der Fall sein
könnte hier soll das erste Plasma in
etwa im Jahr 2025 eingesetzt werden so
dass die Forschungsteams mit ihren
Experimenten beginnen können bis dann
bleibt